africa's largest hydropower project
steeped in decades of dispute has
reached a new milestone
this year's third filling guaranteed 22
billion square meters of water to be
utilized and a turbine operated from the
dam to generate electric power the
mobilization did not harm the downstream
countries or their water share during
the mobilization process the water did
not stop for one day and was flowing and
going to our brothers and ethiopia is
keen to benefit from its resources to
achieve development providing
electricity to our people without
harming others
for ethiopia harnessing the blue nile's
waters to generate affordable
electricity is essential to lift
millions of its people out of poverty
but for those living downstream in sudan
near ethiopia's border it's meant quite
the opposite
our wood used to come from the ethiopian
highlands and we'd fish it out of the
nile
but since the start of the filling of
the ethiopian renaissance dam on the
other side of the border
very few logs come downstream
and instead we have to buy wood from
elsewhere
farmers like mohammed ahmed say they are
seeing changes in the surrounding
environment as well
normally this time of year water levels
are high and they irrigate our farms but
they've been dropping lower and lower
for the past three years and the amount
of fertile soil deposits in the water
has reduced i've lost a lot of my trees
this year because of that
sudan egypt and ethiopia have long tried
to reach an agreement on the operation
of the dam but negotiations have
faltered and ethiopia began filling the
dam in 2020
the countries downstream are concerned
about possible disruptions to the niles
water levels which depend on cycles of
rain in the northern ethiopian highlands
this year or in the next year or coming
here will be
a low flood
period this will affect egypt and sudan
so much because 14 billion cubic meters
in the third
field means
amount of water is enough to irrigate
about 3 million acre of agriculture land
in egypt and sudan and both country
egypt and sudan have a deep gap in food
security
the renaissance arm is expected to be
operational next year while many
ethiopians are eager to reap the
benefits communities downstream fear
their livelihoods could be affected
priyanka gupta al jazeera